- What we're going to do in this video
is think about Monetary Policy,
which is policy that
a Central Bank can use
to affect the economy in some way.
This is often contrasted
with Fiscal Policy,
and that would be a government
deciding to tax or spend in some way
in order to make
adjustments to an economy.
But to help us think
through Monetary Policy
let's bring up our model
for the money market.
And just as a little bit of a review,
here on the horizontal axis
I have the quantity of money,
or else we could imagine that say the M1,
which is cash in circulation
and checkable deposits,
and then here in the vertical axis
we have our nominal interest rate.
In this model we have assumed
a perfectly inelastic money supply;
that's why we have this vertical line,
which isn't exactly how the world works
but we'll go with that for
the sake of this video.
And then we have the
demand curve for money.
At high nominal interest rates,
the opportunity cost of
keeping cash is very high
so people would not want
to keep much of it around.
And then when nominal
interest rates are low
the opportunity cost, or
at least the perceived
opportunity cost of
holding cash is a lot lower
so people might wanna hold more of it
and so you have a higher demand for money.
And this point where the supply
and the demand intersect...
We have seen this before,
this point of equilibrium,
we see that that would result
in our equilibrium nominal interest rate.
But let's say this is
the world that we are in,
and we are in a recessionary
or a negative output gap.
And you are the Central
Bank of this country.
What could you do?
Well in general, you would say
"Well it would be nice if nominal
interest rates were lower,
"then maybe people would
be willing to borrow more,
"there'd be more of a demand for money,
"and they would use that money
in order to make investments,
"or in order to consume more
"and we could close
"that recessionary gap".
But how would you lower interest rates?
Well one way would be to
increase the money supply.
If we could shift this vertical
line to the right somehow.
But how would you do that?
We often talk about Central
Banks printing money
but how did they get that money
actually into circulation?
How did they actually
increase the money supply?
Well there's a couple of
tools at their disposal.
One is the idea of Open Market Operations.
Open Market Operations,
and this is the tool that
Central Banks most typically use.
Let's say that this is a
bond that I currently own,
and a bond is a loan to some
entity and this paper says
"Hey that entity is going to pay you back
"with interest at some
point in the future".
And let's say this is a government bond.
Let's say it's to the U.S. Government.
What the Federal Reserve
might do in the United States,
the Central bank, and this is
how most Central Banks work,
the Federal Reserve says
"Hey, I want to increase
the money supply".
And so they say "Hey I'm gonna go into
"the open market and buy a bond."
So, I might not know
who's buying that bond
but it happens to be the Federal Reserve.
And so instead of selling
it to someone else
who would give me cash that's
already in circulation,
the Federal Reserve
would be introducing new
cash into circulation.
This might be money
that they just printed.
and I'll say printed in quotes,
because there's not a lot of physical cash
or at least as much as there use to be.
These could just be digital numbers
in banking account at certain places.
But it has the same functional idea,
that this is part of the monetary base.
And then we've talked about this before.
You have a money multiplier.
I would put this into a bank,
the bank would loan out a proportion
of that based on the Reserve requirements,
and then whoever gets that
would deposit it in a bank
and that bank could loan
out a certain proportion.
Let's say that the Central Bank
bought this from me for $1000,
and let's say that our current
reserve requirement is equal to 12.5%.
Well the effect on the
money supply over here
won't just be $1,000.
Instead we would move $1,000
times the money multiplier.
And so this would be equal to,
so we would have $1,000,
and what's the multiplier going to be?
Well it's going to be
one over 12.5%, 0.125.
One over 0.125, this
right over here is eight.
So the money multiplier here is eight.
So the effect of buying that $1,000 bond
with new printed currency so to speak,
printed cash so to speak,
would actually be to increase
the money supply by $8,000.
$8,000 increase in money supply.
And obviously $8,000 is not
going to make a big deal
to an economy like the United States.
But imagine if this was $100 billion.
Well then this would be $800
billion right over here.
And what would happen to this curve?
Well it would move over,
let's say it moves over here.
And so this is money supply
curve two, and then this is M2,
and now what is our
equilibrium interest rate?
Well our equilibrium interest rate,
our nominal interest rate
has now gone down; R2.
And this would hopefully have the effect
that the Central Bank wants.
That hey, now that nominal
interest rates have gone down
people might borrow more
for more consumption,
for more investment, and close
that negative output gap.
And it can work the other way as well.
Imagine if in this
situation right over here,
we were in an inflationary output gap.
A positive output gap.
The economy was overheating in some way,
and the Central Bank
wanted to cool things down.
Well the way they could
do is they could say
"Well if interest rates
were a little bit higher
"that might slow things down,
"there might be less
consumption, less investment".
How would they do that?
Well, instead of what they did here
where they bought bonds to inject cash,
they could do the opposite.
They could take bonds
that the Central Bank has
and they could sell those bonds
and then that would take
cash out of the system.
By taking that cash out of the system
it would take reserves out of the system,
and it would have the opposite effect,
and it would shift the
money supply to the left.
And then you would have the
effect of raising rates.
Now another way of
shifting the money supply
to the right or the left here,
increasing or decreasing it,
is by changing the actual
reserve requirement.
This is done less frequently
than the Open Market Operations
but we'll see that that
could have the same effect.
If the Central Bank which can
set the reserve requirement
were to change it from 12.5%,
and were to instead make it let's say 10%,
well then the money multiplier,
money multiplier...
and we've the math in other videos,
it would go from one over 12.5%,
it would go from eight
to one over 10%, to 10.
So the existing reserves,
instead of having an eight
times multiplier on 'em,
you would have a 10
times multiplier on 'em.
And once again, that would have the effect
of increasing the money supply.
Now another tool that's
sometimes associated
with Monetary Policy is
setting the discount rate.
Now the discount window
at the Federal Reserve
in the United States
isn't used in situations
to affect Monetary Policy so much,
as really being a mechanism of safety
for our financial system.
So if a bank is running out of reserves,
and so they can still hold up
their commitments to folks,
they can go to the discount
window of the Federal Reserve
and borrow money directly from the Fed.
And the Federal Reserve
can set this discount rate,
but it really becomes
operational during emergencies.
When you hear about the Federal
Reserve setting the rate,
they're really talking about
the Federal Funds rate.
Federal Funds.
And this is the rate at
which banks lend reserves
to each other over night.
And the banks are going to
be lending to each other
at slightly different rates,
but what the Federal Reserve,
the Central Bank will do
is they'll set a target
Federal Funds rate.
So what they will do is
they will target a Federal Funds rate,
and typically use Open Market Operations
to make that target a reality.
Now the last thing I
want you to appreciate
in this discussion of Monetary Policy,
the things that the Federal Reserve can do
to increase or decrease the money supply,
to decrease or increase
nominal interest rates
is to think about how quickly
these things might happen
and how quickly their effects might be.
There's oftentimes a lag here.
It might take a little time for
the Central Bank to realize,
hey it looks like we're in
an inflationary situation.
Maybe we got to decrease the
money supply a little bit.
Maybe we gotta take a little bit
of reserves out of the system.
Or the other way around,
to realize that they're in a recession.
So there's usually a lag there.
And then even once they act,
they enact this Monetary Policy,
it takes time for it to
fully impact the system.
It takes time for the interest
rates to truly come down.
And even more, once the
interest rates are down
it might take time for people to realize
that hey, maybe I wanna borrow now,
and what would I use that money for?
And for that that to
actually impact the economy.